Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a Russian comedy
Sci Fi film called “The (UN)perfect Guy.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
A
young Russian woman named Sveta lives in a
small apartment with her boyfriend Borya.
Sveta has recently left her job at a car showroom
and is currently interviewing for a job at
a multi-million robotic company.
Her potential boss Vadim Sergeevich, is impressed
by her intelligence and appoints her in his
company as a manager for the next launch.
Sveta is beyond happy while returning home.
She walks into her physical trainer and influencer
boyfriend Borya working out in her kitchen.
Sveta picks up on Borya’s weird behavior
but doesn’t say anything.
A noise is heard from the bathroom which Borya
claims is a client, but his lie is soon caught
when a girl with only a towel comes out of
it.
Sveta looks at her boyfriend with teary eyes
as he makes up excuses.
She also notices him hiding a packet of contraception
on the floor but doesn't call him out for
it.
Borya is clearly cheating on her but Sveta
is too emotionally attached to him, to let
him go.
After the woman leaves, Borya cooks breakfast
for them as an awkward silence prevails in
the kitchen.
Having had enough of Sveta’s silence, he
asks her to speak and curse him because he
deserves it.
Sveta still insists nothing is wrong with
their relationship which makes Borya even
more furious.
He hands her a slipper, urging her to hit
him, but she declines.
Things get heated when he starts to bang his
head to the fridge and throws his dumbbell
off the balcony.
It lands on someone’s car and the couple
is called downstairs to pay for it.
Borya begins arguing with the man even though
it was his fault.
When Sveta stops him, he declares that they
have broken up and leaves.
Sveta is devastated, her mood from the morning
changes entirely and she begins to cry.
The following day is her first day at work.
Her coworker Vit explains everything she has
to do throughout the day.
Her first task is to unpack the human-like
androids, sync them with their tablets, and
ask them for their model number.
Once the number matches, she has to scan the
barcode behind their ears and send them to
room number twentyone for diagnosis.
The androids are so similar to humans that
one can not differentiate between them.
The company has given them all their own personality
and a specific thing they are good at so the
consumers could buy one according to their
need.
The first box that Sveta opens is a well-built
fitness trainer.
Sveta carefully takes the tablet from beside
him and links him to it.
His neck, which was made of iron till now,
starts to transform to look like a human.
When the robot opens its eyes, it startles
Sveta.
She is confused about what she should do next
but the smart robot briefs her.
Sveta does as he says and sends him for evaluation.
Next, she opens a box with a beautiful model
inside it.
She, too, is as smart as the first guy.
By her third time, Sveta gets a hang of the
job and does it efficiently.
She unpacks a cook, a political leader, a
maid, and other robots.
However, her skills are tested when a box
with a “friend” doesn’t want to tell
her his model number.
He refuses to get up and says that he just
had a really horrible dream.
Sveta believes that he might have a defect
and asks him to go to the evacuation room
but he states that he is scared and hugs her.
She calls Vit and informs him about the situation.
He almost doesn’t believe her until he sees
the friend for himself.
On checking, he finds out that the friend
has the error number 102.
The robot is scared because this might mean
they will demolish him to create a new and
better robot.
He starts to cry about how short his life
was.
Even while crying, he compliments Sveta’s
beauty because he cannot help it; flirting
and being friendly is coded in his program.
Their boss Vadim Sergeevich is called for
the final verdict of the situation.
He wants to send the defective one back to
Japan but Sveta retaliates, saying that they
can sell him at a discount because of the
defect.
Vadim Sergeevich agrees and asks her to prepare
the robots for the potential clients.
Following that, they are kept on platforms
for an exhibition so the clients can chat
with them and decide which one to get.
Sveta is nervous because she has to present
the robots to the clients.
She tells the friend that her confidence is
low because her boyfriend just broke up with
her but he assures her she will do great.
A wealthy woman comes looking for a suitable
robot and Sveta introduces her to the friend.
She is skeptical about buying him at first
but changes her mind when he flatters her
with several compliments.
However, while trying to win her acceptance,
the friend starts getting weirdly sexual.
Yet, the woman asks Sveta to pack him up until
she comes to pick him up.
Later, when Sveta is working on her computer,
the friend approaches her and apologizes for
his inappropriate jokes.
He also thanks her for being such a good salesperson
and compliments her talent.
As they talk, he suggests she buy him so they
can be good friends forever.
Sveta laughs and claims that he is out of
her budget.
The friend reveals that he cracked the inappropriate
joke on purpose because if he was selected,
he would never meet her again.
Then, he gets closer to Sveta and kisses her
on the lips but she immediately backs up.
At last, they share an awkward hug and separate.
The next day, the company holds a runway show
to display all the robots.
The show is a success and most of them are
sold out quickly.
At the end of the day, Vadim Sergeevich is
drunk and cannot drive home himself.
Vit offers to drive Vadim Sergeevich and Sveta
to their houses.
On their way home, Vit invites Sveta to a
concert that is four months away.
It is evident that he has started to like
her.
They sing songs throughout the journey.
When they reach Sveta’s apartment, Vadim
Sergeevich insists on taking her to her room
although he is drunk.
He falls asleep on the couch, so Sveta doesn’t
bother to wake him up and goes to sleep herself.
When she returns to work the following day,
she is surprised to see that the woman has
already taken the friend away.
Although it is her first successful sale and
she should be happy, something doesn’t feel
right.
Just then, she gets a text from the friend.
He has sent her a video thanking her for being
his friend even if it was only for a day.
He even recites a self-written poem for her.
Sveta is left smitten after listening to it.
She cannot help but call his owner with the
excuse of checking up on him.
The friend excitedly tells her that his owner
is making him wear an animal onesie.
He says that he misses her before hanging
up.
The next day at work, his owner barges in
complaining about the robot’s behavior.
The friend follows her behind and says that
he doesn’t want to stay with her because
she makes him wear stupid clothes and treats
him like a slave which hurts his pride.
Vadim Sergeevich apologizes to the customer
and ensures her a full refund.
He is furious at the friend for making his
company look bad.
As he hits the robot, Sveta stops him, claiming
that she will buy him instead.
For the next few days, she collects money
from her friend Katya, her mother, and from
the bank and finally brings the friend home.
At night, he sleeps on the floor beside her
bed.
They discuss a name for him and decide on
Yegor.
Sveta wakes up the next morning to Yegor making
her a delicious breakfast.
He sends her off to work and texts her the
whole day.
The two are slowly but surely falling in love.
One evening, Sveta goes to hang out with her
best friend Katya who is expecting to be proposed
to by her boyfriend soon.
She invites Sveta and Yegor to her birthday
party and asks her to stay in the front row,
confident that she is going to be proposed
to.
One day, Yegor is alone at home when Borya
walks in and asks him who he is.
Yegor believes that he is an intruder and
punches him in the face.
He also avoids all of Borya’s attacks.
Seeing his unique personality, Borya challenges
him to a pull-up competition and broadcasts
it live to his million followers.
An innocent Yegor agrees to compete.
The live video goes viral and a lot of people
join in.
Sveta also sees it and rushes home to find
a drunk Borya and Yegor in the front of her
building.
She turns Yegor’s power off and brings him
to the apartment.
She is furious at him for hanging out with
her ex-boyfriend without her permission.
Yegor asks her if she is still in love with
Borya, clearly jealous.
Sveta realizes how he feels and the two kiss
for the first time.
That evening, they go to Katya’s birthday
party and meet her.
Katya’s boyfriend asks her to come to the
stage but never proposes to her.
She loses her patience and asks him for the
ring, embarrassing herself in front of everyone.
Then, she runs to the back room, crying about
the horrible night.
Sveta follows her behind and makes Yegor sit
with her while she goes to meet Katya’s
boyfriend.
Borya is also at the party showing everything
live to his followers.
Katya’s boyfriend tells Sveta that he is
gay which is also heard on Instagram live.
They go to tell Katya the truth but find her
giving sexual favor to Yegor.
Sveta loses her mind and hits Katya with a
bottle.
However, she moves at the last moment and
the bottle hits Yegor, breaking his jaw.
Sveta takes him home and invites Vit to repair
his face.
Sometime later, she takes off the bandage
from his face and sees that Vit has changed
his face altogether.
Her day gets worse when she goes to the office
and gets fired because of the live video of
yesterday’s event that went viral on the
internet.
Even while getting fired, she asks for a new
face for Yegor but Vadim Sergeevich dismisses
her.
So, she takes help from Vit and sneaks into
the warehouse at night.
They look through the model of the boxes and
finally find the one they were looking for.
But their plan goes south when they realize
Vadim Sergeevich has been watching them while
on a bed with the model robot.
He fires Vit from the job for bringing Sveta
in but lets them have the face for Yegor.
On the ride back home, Sveta feels bad for
Vit but he assures her that he will find a
new job soon.
He is in love with her but knows that they
cannot be together because of Yegor.
Sveta gives Yegor his old face back and the
two start living like a happy couple.
They start a youtube family channel together
and turn into huge influencers because of
the uniqueness of their relationship.
One day, Yegor proposes to Sveta on Instagram
live.
She says yes and jumps around in happiness.
In the following scene, Sveta is walking down
the aisle to marry the love of her life.
The pastor is a beautiful young lady.
She asks Yegor if he takes Sveta as his wife
but instead of saying yes, he flirts with
the pastor.
Sveta loses her patience when he asks for
her number.
Humiliated at her own wedding, she runs back
home.
Yegor follows her behind trying to pass his
flirting as a glitch in his program.
But Sveta has made up her mind.
She cries and asks him why he did that to
her but Yegor lashes out at her, calling her
a weakling.
Vit arrives at the right time and reveals
that error 109, is not actually an error,
it is a feature that every friend robot has,
because of which they mirror all the activities
of the person who first talks to them.
So, up until now, Yegor has been mirroring
Sveta.
He cheated on her with Katya because Sveta
wanted Katya to get over her boyfriend.
Even now, he is yelling at her because she
is doing the same to him.
Yegor realizes that he will only hurt her
if he stays in her life.
So, he hands her the remote and asks her to
turn him off and send him back to Japan.
They kiss for the last time before she presses
the button.
Six months after the incident, Sveta wakes
up and goes to the kitchen to see Vit cooking
for her.
He loves her more than anyone has ever had.
While eating, she gets a text from Yegor for
the first time since they last talked.
She locks herself in the bathroom and watches
the video.
Yegor says he is now in Japan and is happy.
He also claims that he remembers all the time
they spent together because those were the
best moments in his life.
Sveta watches the video with a smile on her
face as Yegor sings for her in a Japanese
warehouse.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.